I invited friends over to play music and
jam and I was just a very casual party
forget who it was I think I might have
been like Salma Hayek like because I
know she was very very close to him and
she said a prince is coming over this is
my house now well and I was like what
we're like we suck this is not cool
you're gonna find a like and I was like
it wasn't a great party there's like 15
people there it was kind of like weren't
wearing he shows up and it was literally
like it was as if we were in a movie
where Prince shows up with a band and
like it's like a hostile takeover of the
music we were just like [ __ ] and
like playing shitty riffs so he walks in
and he's like you mind if we play and he
just goes to three point but just
launches it to this thing and you're
like holy [ __ ] he's bringing down my
house literally like the walls were
shaking and they're just rock kicking
ass something breaks like and I kind of
hear my guitar crapping out on my Comic
Cons [ __ ] whoa guitars breaking some
lose his mind he's out of here right and
he like doesn't hand gesture and the
band kind of stops on a dime he's like
let's go to my house like tell all your
people to come to my house right now and
it's like was annoying at this point Wow
and so like [ __ ] okay like we'll go to
your house now print or we have like a
huge full ballroom style you know
incredible setup I have my guitar
strapped on my back like I was 19 you
know in the car like all giddy come
little princes house you know we have
some drinks we hang out he plays us like
his entire new record Wow and he's like
hey get up here anywhere shading solos
and jamming and [ __ ] and what do you do
at like 6:00 7:00 in the morning like 5
or 6 you know wow he's prints dude yeah
like I'm sorry look you can nerd out
about certain people like Prince's
[ __ ] prints and I'll always put him
on this pedestal when Prince died we put
out that video you playing the Prince
song
[Music]
when I covered Purple Rain I know that
he said he'd get in it oh yeah
getting it well that's my [ __ ] hi
players you know the him saying that is
basically like to be exactly the highest
praise yeah it was didn't [ __ ] it up
alright good because it's really easy to
[ __ ] that song up